[Music]
this is a bit of a change cuz I see you
around the lot you we should have the
same what you were never dressed this
nicely
well it sure you're always in every time
I see you you're in sweats and
flip-flops
those aren't sweats Conan what are they
Lululemon high-end yoga wear yeah okay
I look like McConaughey between movies
you know isn't this the company that was
busted for having liked being able to
see your ass because the fabric was too
sheer exactly and some people said you
can see the woman's ass other people
said and what's the problem you know
maybe that's why the ladies like it on
you Pete thank you john c reilly well
I'm just curious if I be quiet I told
you be quiet at him that's not a chia
pet I will
I one time was on this very show and
mentioned Cap'n Crunch and I got a bunch
of free Captain Crunch sent to me
well I I talked about stealing sugar
pops if you admit you stole it you don't
get more of it for free I don't think
when he said I would have preferred it
to that was smart yeah you're gonna get
some Captain Crunch I can't eat another
single sugar pop for the rest of my life
after 500 boxes in the basement though
that's funny you say that because I'd
never stopped loving sugar corn
you're not we're not concerned with
telling kids to rob trains but when it
comes to criticizing sugar corn pops we
got to let folks know like yeah that's
off that's not a bounce kids yeah yeah
know what it takes yeah get that
delicious taste in your mouth yeah sugar
corn pops yeah kill a guy now you I
think I know where you got your casual
style because I've met your family and
particularly your dad yeah dad not a guy
that likes to dress up well my father
Jay Holmes came to a taping of the Pete
Holmes show and he was wearing Tevas
swim trunks and a Red Sox jersey that's
completely true his one good pair of
pants had oil on them mm-hmm he realized
that upon unpacking them so he just went
with the swim trunks and the Teebs and
yeah this is true actually a lot of
people saw him and thought something was
wrong well yeah he was you know dressed
very very very casually that was just
the beginning of the problem my father
said roughly over there if this were my
set and he was in the second row and the
guest was Rob Corddry so there's my
father in swim trunks kind of a weird
choice and I'm interviewing Rob Corddry
just like you're interviewing us and in
the middle of it my father who's from
Boston goes who is this guy for everyone
here yes it's a part of the show Rob
Corddry was like what was that I was
like that was my father